>> Jesse: LET'S TAKE US BACK TO
THE ELECTION.
TRUMP WAS DOING THE YMCA DANCE.
BIDEN COULDN'T SPELL YMCA AMY
BARRETT SAILING THROUGH AND WARP
SPEED AROUND THE CORNER.
AND REMEMBER THE OCTOBER
SURPRISE.
THE "NEW YORK POST" AIRED HUNTER
BIDEN'S DIRTIEST LAUNDRY THANKS
TO HIS LAPTOP FROM HELL
ABANDONED AT THE REPAIR SHOP IN
DELAWARE.
IF YOU WERE WATCHING THIS
CHANNEL, YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT
IT.
THAT WAS NEWS.
BUT IF YOU WERE LISTENING TO THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA'S RUSSIAN STYLE
PROPAGANDA, COURTESY OF THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN, YOU WERE
WATCHING THE BIGGEST
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN ALMOST
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
ON DAY ONE, WHEN THE "NEW YORK
POST" BROKE THE STORY,
JOURNALISTS AROUND THE COUNTRY
SWOOPED IN TO DEBUNK THE LAPTOP
AND ALL OF THE SECRETS THAT
LURKED INSIDE.
THEY LABELED IT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
FAKE NEWS.
ARTICLES LIKE THIS WERE
SURFACING ALL OVER.
THE TRUTH BEHIND THE HUNTER
BIDEN'S NON-SCANDAL.
JEN PSAKI WAS QUICK TO PULL THE
TRIGGER AT THE TIME.
SHE SAID, QUOTE:  THE HUNTER
BIDEN STORY IS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
THEY ALL SOUNDED LIKE PARROTS.
ANNOYING US WITH THE SAME
TALKING POINTS.
EVEN CIA OFFICIALS PUT OUT A
LETTER CLAIMING THIS COULDN'T BE
TRUE.
WHO ASKED THE CIA ANYWAY.
ANYONE THAT REPORTED ON THE
LAPTOP OR ITS COB TENTS WAS
SPREADING DISINFORMATION.
AND THEY WERE SENSORRED IN
AMERICA.
NOT RUSSIA.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THEY EVEN KICKED THE POST OFF
TWITTER THE COUNTRY'S OLDEST
NEWSPAPER.
THEY CONSPIRED AFTERNOON HUNTER
GRABBED THE MOP WITH THE CLEAN
UP JOB.
>> FOR REAL, I DON'T KNOW.
>> I REALLY DON'T KNOW IS WHAT
THE ANSWER.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW YES OR NO IF
THE LAPTOP WAS YOURS.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> SO IT COULD HAVE BEEN YOURS.
>> CERTAINLY.
THERE COULD BE A LAPTOP OUT
THERE THAT WAS STOLEN FROM ME.
THERE COULD BE THAT I WAS
HACKED.
IT COULD BE THAT THERE WAS
THE -- THAT IT WAS RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE.
>> Jesse: RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN SUCCESS.
ONE IN FIVE WOULD HAVE CHANGED
THEIR VOTES IF THEY HAD KNOWN
ABOUT THE HUNTER LAPTOP.
IF YOU WENT THROUGH ALL OF THAT
YOU WOULD BE PRETTY SURPRISED
TODAY WHEN YOU OPENED UP THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
AND PEALED IT OPEN ALL THE WAY
BACK TO PAGE 20 TO SEE THIS
HEADLINE, QUOTE:  HUNTER BIDEN
PAID TAX BILL BUT BROAD FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION CONTINUES.
IS THIS THE FIRST TIME THEY HAVE
MENTIONED THE INVESTIGATION INTO
HUNTER'S SKETCHY BUSINESS DEAL?
THE "TIMES" REPORTS THAT THIS
ALL STARTED OFF WITH A TAX AUDIT
UNDER THE OBAMA-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THEN IT SOON TURNED CRIMINAL
WHEN HIS DAD WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
SO, YOU ARE TELLING ME THAT THE
OBAMA-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
STARTED LOOKING INTO BIDEN'S
SON'S TAXES AND BIDEN'S SON
NEVER SAID ANYTHING TO HIS DAD
ABOUT IT LIKE HEY, DAD, WHY IS
YOUR IRS AUDITING ME?
THERE IS NO WAY JOE DIDN'T KNOW.
AND THEN YOUR FATHER IS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT AND THE FEDS OPEN
UP A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO
YOU FOR MONEY LAUNDERING AND YOU
DON'T PULL YOUR DAD ASIDE AND
SAY HEY, POP, THERE IS THIS
LITTLE THING THAT MAY COME UP
DURING THE CAMPAIGN?
NOT A HUGE DEAL BUT I'M KIND OF
UNDER INVESTIGATION?
OF COURSE HUNTER TOLD JOE THAT.
JOE KNEW THE WHOLE TIME THE
LAPTOP WAS REAL.
AND SO DID THE "NEW YORK TIMES."
HIDDEN, DEEP INSIDE THAT ARTICLE
WAS AN ADMISSION, QUOTE:  THOSE
EMAILS WERE OBTAINED BY THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" FROM A KACH OF PILES
THAT APPEARS TO COME FROM A
LAPTOP ABANDONED BY MR. BIDEN IN
A DELAWARE REPAIR SHOP.
THE EMAIL AND OTHERS IN THE
CACHE WERE AUTHENTICATED BY
PEOPLE FAMILIAR WITH THEM AND
WITH THE INVESTIGATION.
SO WE WERE RIGHT ABOUT HUNTER
BEING PAID $3.5 MILLION BY A
RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE.
SO YOU ARE SAYING WE WERE RIGHT
ABOUT HUNTER BEING GIVEN A THREE
CARROT DIAMOND FROM A CHINESE
COMMUNIST BUSINESSMAN?
THREE CARROTS.
THAT'S A BIG ROCK.
WHEN A MAN GIVES ANOTHER MAN A
DIAMOND, IT'S ONE OF TWO THINGS.
AN ENGAGEMENT OR A BRIBE.
NOW, HUNTER IS INTO SOME WEIRD
STUFF WE WILL CALL IT AN
INDECENT PROPOSAL.
WE WERE RIGHT ABOUT THE $50,000
A MONTH HE WAS MAKING AS A GAS
EXPERT WORKING FOR BURISMA.
AND THAT HUNTER ARRANGED FOR HIS
DAD TO MEET WITH BURISMA
LOBBYISTS BEFORE HE FIRED THE
PROSECUTOR.
WE WERE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
AND IF WE ARE RIGHT ABOUT ALL OF
THIS, BECAUSE THE LAPTOP HAS
BEEN PROVEN REAL BY THE PAPER OF
RECORD.
THEN THAT MUST MEAN JOE BIDEN
REALLY IS THE BIG GUY.
>> AND THEN IT HAS 10% FOR THE
BIG GUY HELD BY H.
I 1,000 PERCENT SIT HERE AND
KNOW THAT THE BIG GUY IS
REFERENCING JOE BIDEN.
IT'S -- THAT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR TO
ME BECAUSE I LIVED IT.
>> Jesse: AND THE BIG GUY LIED
WHEN HE WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
LISTEN.
>> TOTALLY DISCREDITED.
AND, BY THE WAY.
>> WAIT HE DIDN'T GET
$2.5 MILLION, JOE?
HE GOT $3.5 MILLION.
>> THAT IS NOT TRUE.
MY SON DID NOTHING WRONG IN
BURISMA.
>> I THINK HE DID.
>> LET HIM ANSWER.
>> HE DOESN'T WANT ME TO ANSWER
BECAUSE HE KNOWS I HAVE THE
TRUTH.
HIS POSITION HAS BEEN TOTALLY
DISCREDITED.
>> WITH WHO BY THE MEDIA.
>> IT'S HARD TO GET ANY WORD IN
WITH THIS CLOWN.
>> BIG TECH LIED AND SPREAD
DANGEROUS MISINFORMATION TO WIN
AN ELECTION.
AND IT GETS WORSE, IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE IT JOE WAS KNEE DEEP IN
HUNTER'S FINANCES.
SHARED BANK ACCOUNTS, CREDIT
CARDS, PAYING EACH OTHER'S BILLS
WITH DIRTY FOREIGN MONEY?
THE LAPTOP AND THE EMAILS
CONFIRM THOSE ACCUSATIONS.
HE WAS ALLEGEDLY CUTTING 10%
HERE AND THERE IN EXCHANGE FOR
SECRET MEETINGS WITH SKETCHY
CHINESE BUSINESSMEN AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WHILE HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT.
HE TOOK MEETINGS AT CAFE MILANO
IN WASHINGTON.
PRETTY GOOD PLACE WITH SOME
UKRAINIANS AND RUSSIANS AND
KAZAKHSTANY BUSINESSMEN THAT
HUNTER WAS TRYING TO STRIKE UP
DEALS WITH.
>> I MET WITH THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT IN PERSON MULTIPLE
TIMES AND I HAD BEEN MEETING AND
TALKING WITH HUNTER BIDEN AND
JIM BIDEN AND ROB WALKER AND
JAMES GILYARD.
>> OH, THE BIDEN BROTHERS, TOO.
AND JOE DIDN'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH ANY OF THIS WHY WOULD HE?
HIS FAMILY WAS GETTING FILTHY
RICH.
REMEMBER HOW SMART HUNTER BIDEN
IS?
>> HE IS A GROWN MAN.
HE IS THE SMARTEST MAN I KNOW.
I MEAN, PURE INTELLECTUAL
CAPACITY.
AND -- AND AS LONG AS HE IS
GOOD, WE ARE GOOD.
>> Jesse: JOE SAYS HUNTER IS THE
SMARTEST GUY HE KNOWS.
THE SMARTEST GUY.
WOW.
MAYBE THAT EXPLAINS AFGHANISTAN
AND THE BORDER AND INFLATION AND
GAS PRICES.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED WHEN JEN
PSAKI WAS ASKED ABOUT THIS STORY
TODAY.
>> THE "NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
AUTHENTICATED EMAILS THAT APPEAR
TO HAVE COME FROM A LAPTOP
ABANDONED BY HUNTER BIDEN IN
DELAWARE.
THE PRESIDENT PREVIOUSLY SAID
THAT THE "NEW YORK POST" STORY
ABOUT THIS WAS A BUNCH OF
GARBAGE AND RUSSIAN PLANT.
DOES HE STAND BY THAT.
>> I POINT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND HUNTER BIDEN'S
PREPPIVE.
HE DOESN'T WORK IN THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> Jesse: HUNTER DOESN'T WORK IN
GOVERNMENT?
YES, HE DOES.
IT'S THE FAMILY BUSINESS.
HUNTER IS THE FAMILY LOBBYIST.
EXCUSE ME, HUNTER IS ALSO A VERY
TALENTED PAINTER.
AND IF FOREIGN AGENTS WANT TO
SPEND QUART TILL MILL TO BUY
INFLUENCE I MEAN A PAINT FRGHTS
FIRST FAMILY, WELL, THE WHITE
HOUSE DOESN'T HAVE A COMMENT.
IF THEY DO, IT'